don't expect to hear this word when you
watch Creed 3. here's why Tessa Thompson
absolutely refused to say this word on
camera Tessa Thompson isn't pulling any
bunches when it comes to shaping her
Creed 3 character while Adonis Creed's
Journey on the Silver Screen has largely
been shaped by the guidance and training
he's received from Rocky Balboa it's
important to note just how important
Bianca is to the boxing Superstar a
musician Thompson's character was first
introduced in 2015's Creed where she
served as adonis's love interest and
emotional Rock Creed wasn't just a
one-off a box office Juggernaut and
Oscar nominee it went on to spawn a
successful sequel in 2018. now it's
three equal time and Thompson's
character is just as relevant as she was
on day one with Bianca such a key part
of the Creed mythology Thompson has made
it clear just how important it is for
her to shape Bianca the actor said as
much in an exclusive interview with
Looper where she opened up about being
Hands-On without the Creed character has
evolved she said something that feels
exciting is that I've always been
invited to be kind of a co-author and
figure that out with the collaborators
while speaking with The Hollywood
Reporter Tessa Thompson opened up about
the importance of maintaining Bianca's
character Arc throughout the franchise
in Creed 3 Bianca and Adonis are living
the good life enjoying their success and
fame because life is so cozy in Los
Angeles a part of Bianca namely her
affinity for Philadelphia is less
visible on screen in the first Creed
Bianca and Adonis first begin to fall in
love over cheesesteaks a Philadelphia
staple on their date Bianca explains to
Adonis the meaning behind John which has
strong Philadelphia Roots Mr John it's a
noun it's like a save Jesus Jones this
is a join this restaurant was sitting in
Mr John yeah we're John while the scene
doesn't have the momentum or high stakes
of Adonis training or fighting it does
allow Bianca and the boxer to bond
eventually leading to their relationship
which is at the heart of Creed 3 because
Jon is so uniquely Philly Thompson
refused to use it in the LA focused
Creed 3. I said to them I'm not saying
John in this movie because we've heard
it we've done it I want to break new
territory not saying John was also a way
of saying inside of the filmmaking that
you are going to witness someone that is
constantly evolving Bianca's Evolution
from up-and-coming musician to Rockstar
a talented producer has been a powerful
emotional Arc of the Creed Trilogy and
subtly acknowledging how far she's come
from the Philly musician we met in the
first film as an interesting and daring
route for the character and Thompson
doing her best to make Bianca feel like
a real person is nothing new for the
actress in a 2015 interview with the
source Thompson revealed that she had
never been to Philadelphia prior to the
first film films production I never
stepped foot in Philly before I flew
here to make the movie and I spent about
two months before shooting just getting
integrated and learning the dialect and
hanging out in the musical scene in a
separate Interview With The Hollywood
Reporter Thompson opened up about how
she spent hours with Philly natives to
learn the vernacular that persisted
throughout the city years later it's
interesting to see how invested Thompson
is with the character to the point that
she refuses to use a word that's so
synonymous with Philly culture now that
it's no longer applicable as Bianca
becomes more attached to Los Angeles is
it possible that she's becoming more
personal to Thompson who was born in
California Metropolis with Creed 3 the
future of the franchise is open-ended so
here's hoping we get more of Bianca and
Creed as they tackle their next major
battle
foreign